[Music]
i'm going to bring this back to
how you think about
success in investing and i hate that
word so i'll
i'll parse it out a little bit but i
want to read something from a blog post
that you wrote or an article i'm not
sure which you prefer this is uh on the
collaborative fund website internal
versus external benchmarks
and let me just read these two
paragraphs
all right the most important point may
be this internal benchmarks are only
possible when you have some degree of
independence the only way to
consistently do what you want when you
want with whom you want for as long as
you want is to detach from other
people's benchmarks and judge everything
simply by whether you're happy and
fulfilled okay i want to bold that in
your mind judge everything simply by
whether you're happy and fulfilled which
varies person to person this next
paragraph i circled because i just
thought it was
really worth reading over and over again
i recently had dinner with a financial
advisor who had a client that gets angry
when hearing about portfolio returns or
benchmarks none of that matters to the
client all he cares about is whether he
has enough money to keep traveling with
his wife that's his sole benchmark quote
everyone else can stress out about
outperforming each other he says quote i
just like europe end quote maybe he's
got it all figured out so i just love
that because it's like it is a
it is it's highly subjective meaning
it's personal but it's also very
objective it's an absolute measure and
it's an it's it's an example of you know
unless he gets a lot of lifestyle bloat
and wants to have a yacht in the
mediterranean or something
it is a goal post that won't move
all right so you talk about the
importance of the goal posts not moving
in my experience with people who have
gone from
very very moderate circumstances
not having much money growing up to
being very very successful
offhand i'm sure there are some examples
but 99 of the people who come to mind
who are smart i think good people who
are very much students of life the goal
posts have always moved
and so i want to know
what you've seen work or not work in
that
specific domain and
how you think about it for yourself
i think it's it's the single most
important topic
in money in investing in finance and
it's the hardest thing to actually make
work those are both true statements it's
the same for me i can write about this
and say what people should do but it's
the same for my wife and i like we
struggle with this as much as anyone
else about getting the goalposts to stop
moving i think if there is one thing
that has helped me and i would say helps
not fix just like i helped a little bit
around the edges it's something that we
talked about earlier which is that just
the idea the observation that no one is
thinking about you as much as you are
and therefore so much of people's
willingness and their desire to spend
more is just a social signal to show
people how much money you have whether
that's the bigger house the nicer car
like whatever it is like you just want
to show other people and once you
realize that people aren't thinking
about you that much they don't care
about you that much they're thinking
about themselves and how much people
care about them
once you realize that then you're like
okay i i can see what the game is it's a
game that i can't win so i'm not even
going to try to play it i'm just gonna i
just wanna focus on the internal of like
what's gonna make me happy what do i
want what's actually gonna give me
pleasure and let's just do that and i
don't wanna think about anyone else so
much of this is just selfish what's the
happy and whatever the other thing i
bolded which i could probably forgot
but what are those things for you i want
to wake up every morning and hang out
with my kids and i want them to be happy
and i want to do it on my own schedule
if it's a wednesday morning and i don't
want to work then i'm going to sit on
the couch all day and watch netflix and
if it's a sunday and i got a good idea
i'm going to spend all day working it's
all my own schedule on my own time
whatever i want to do it's that
independence and autonomy
can you not do that right now
yeah i can there was a point when i
couldn't and that's why i feel like i'm
i'm pretty happy and i feel like i've
done a decent job of doing that now i do
have as a lot of people would a tendency
to be like oh what if i got that porsche
what if we got the bigger house what if
we did this what if we did that and it's
fun to think that because i love nice
cars i love nice i love all of that it's
just so easy to realize there's a great
quote that i love that's the grass is
always greener on the side that's
fertilized with [ __ ] i think that's
that's really what it is that's the
accurate phrasing of that of that
well-known quote and
i think that's really what it is like
the idea that all that nicer stuff is
gonna make you necessarily happier i
think is just so easy to disprove
especially once you've experienced a
little bit of it yourself and that
actually what is gonna make people happy
is that independence and autonomy that
once i remind myself of that i'm like
okay and then the game of earning more
just becomes
a game it's less about like oh if i have
more money i'm going to be happier no if
my net worth is 10x what it is today i'm
not going to be any happier that was not
true at one point in my life but i think
it's true today it's probably true for
you right now it's true for a lot of
people listening and therefore you can
admit that a game is fun and the game is
fun to play but just admit that it's a
game and it's actually not going to make
you happier
you